hello and welcome to footnotes as per
the usual I'm here to recap the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today I'm
predicting the future but only in a
frustratingly vague way in a profile of
venture capitalist Mary Meeker in our
October issue she's referred to as the
Nostradamus of Technology Nostradamus is
of course the most famous of the
supposed seers folks who claim to
predict the future less famous is the
psychic around the corner from my
apartment who has to advertise but like
everybody else Nostradamus could not
predict the future
he was just good at writing sufficiently
cryptic quatrains his most famous
friction concerns three anti-christ and
some including the damn History Channel
say that two have already come and gone
Napoleon and Hitler oddly these
Antichrist had one common downfall
invading Russia one would think that the
true Antichrist would only be vulnerable
to oh I don't know nothing short of
Christ himself Nostradamus predictions
were downright silly not to mention
extremely vague take this gem for
instance the great swarm of bees will
arise such that one will not know whence
they have come which is generally how
bees work by the way because they can
fly by night the ambush The Sentinel
under the vines city delivered by five
babblers not naked and they better not
be naked what with all the bees around
the truth is no one can predict the
future unless we're using scientific
probabilities for instance I can stay
with a relative confidence that tomorrow
mary meeker will still be very rich and
the History Channel will still be
obsessed with Hitler
next up pigeons from we need jerks of
the urban landscape gadget lab reported
on recent updates to linked in quoting a
company executive as saying they didn't
want to pigeonhole themselves pigeon
holing means too rigidly assign
something to a certain cat
like Nostradamus being pigeon-holed as a
seer when he was also very good at
tennis this term traces back to medieval
times when folks raised pigeons in
little cubby holes you see people were
cuckoo for pigeon meat called squab
which I'm told tastes vaguely of gutters
the term pigeon hole was eventually
applied to a small compartment in a desk
where things could be filed and
categorized hence the term pigeon holing
but pigeons are good for more than food
and making you late for things like
getting in the way when you're trying to
hurry down city sidewalks and force him
to think briefly just briefly they
should gently ever so gently boot it
away without anyone seeing and then you
feel guilty for being so cold-hearted
but you just know that everyone else has
the same savage idea anyway patrons have
an amazing ability to find their way
home from up to 1,000 miles away before
radios the message burying carrier
pigeons were indispensable in battle and
even saw action in both world wars if it
gets a good tailwind it's not hard to
imagine a carrier pigeon reaching the 88
miles per hour required for time travel
potentially traveling to the future and
bringing a message back to the past so
Nostradamus might have predicted the
future by keeping carrier pigeons just
as long as he could resist eating them
you